if you had to face legendary
shape-shifting monsters that skinned its
victims alive what would you do you'll
be forced to face off against a hybrid
mutant demigod and will be forced to
watch it kill everyone you love I'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat
Claymore this chick is going to regret
not slaughtering her own kind Teresa
here is the most lethal Hunter on the
planet coming from a class of half human
half monster Warriors she lives to fight
to terrifying creatures known as the
Yoma flesh-eating demons that feed on
humans she just finishes killing iyoma
in the village and tells the town's folk
that her Handler will come by later to
collect payment for the job the
villagers try to underpay her but she
says that if they do her kind will not
come to help them anymore and without
them their Village will soon be overrun
with bloodthirsty Yoma and the only ones
that can kill Yoma are her kind other
villagers have tried not to pay them
they all paid a terrible price this
woman is known as a clay way more she
leaves town to meet up with her Handler
or say who gives her her next assignment
reaching a new Village the villagers
think this freak is here to save them
but she begins slaughtering them one by
one it's a bloodbath and everyone
screams in Terror this guy tries to run
for help but Teresa splits his face in
half everybody thinks that this Claymore
has gone crazy but that's when all of
the dead bodies on the ground start
turning into Yoma corpses Teresa calls
all of them a bunch of idiots and says
it serves this Village right because
they had no idea that this Village was
being used as a nest for countless Yoma
these creatures absorb the mind and
memories and thinking patterns of their
victims which is why humans can't detect
them she counts the bodies but senses
that there's one more looking at this
man holding a little girl she rushes
past him splitting him in half and his
blood spews on this little girl later
Teresa prepares to leave the town but
gets stopped by the little girl from
earlier she finds out that this girl was
being used as the yomas hostage she has
been put through horrible things and is
now too scared to speak she tells the
little girl that she only killed the
Yoma because it was her job and nothing
more the girl tries to hug Teresa but
gets knocked down hard and Teresa
quickly leaves town heading into the
forest she discovers that the little
girl has followed her all the way here
getting mad she threatens her but just
then they hear footsteps approaching and
Teresa's military training takes over
she cuts this man's hat clean off and
they've discovered they've run into
Bandits and the bandits recognize that
she's a claymore and prepare to retreat
but their leader reveals some bad news
for Teresa he states that it is against
their warrior code to kill humans and if
they do they will be hunted down and
brutally murdered as a punishment by
their own kind according to their own
rules Theresa can't touch them no matter
what they do to her the little girl's
heart starts racing in fear and the
bandits Hearts start to race in
excitement while wearing some so
here's what we gotta do in order to
survive I'm gonna let him eat my
let me explain Claymores are highly
skilled Warriors trained by a mysterious
organization that probably is very evil
at least from the looks of things and
they're kind of like Captain America in
terms of powers and they can further
increase their powers even more by
activating their Yoma which is actually
an inner demon power that they all have
but what doesn't make sense is that why
Teresa didn't have any backup plans for
this exact situation because if I was
Theresa I would have questioned this
from the beginning the rule of not
killing humans was set in place by a
mysterious organization that I work for
why would we have that rule sure we live
to serve humans but we can't even touch
them even in self-defense I don't like
this because if I think about it a
little more it's easier to figure out
from the beginning that the organization
doesn't exactly care about me and Views
me as Expendable knowing that we are
expendable I think we should install
some sort of security measure in place
in order to prevent this exact situ
situation from ever happening now
looking as sexy as I do it's only
natural to think that our bod was going
to get some serious attention and since
we can't harm any humans we need to
think that this bodaciousness of mine is
actually literal I'll explain in
the wild certain plants possess the
ability to emit foul smells similar to
Rotting Flesh as a survival mechanism in
order to deter less bees from
pollinating them as well as some other
reasons that I don't bother talking
about I'm going to copy this move and
find certain stinky plants and I'm going
to ground them up and I'm going to
spread it all over my body this way even
if the bad guys wanted a taste they'd
have to be down pretty bad to want to
have a taste of this nasty because it's
gonna smell really bad the bandits start
chuckling and decide to get a taste of
Theresa and then she smiles and then
rips off her clothes revealing her
horribly scarred chest she tells them to
come get it and her willingness repulses
the men and they decide to leave her
instead carrying away the man that she
injured and he yells that she will pay
for this Teresa then tries to leave the
little girl girl but she ends up
following her until the next morning
when she finally starts to get tired
Teresa now relieved jumps down this
Cliff but is shocked to see this girl
follow her down this high cliff and she
comes crashing down and passes out now
Teresa is already more than happy to
leave the little girl but she realizes
that if this little girl dies then she
might be blamed for her death annoyed
she decides to try and wake her up in
this River giving her food and water she
tells the little girl that she will
escort her to the next town to make sure
she survives and once they get there
they will part ways they continue on
with their journey and throughout the
day they bond over some really cute
stuff it is cute by the end of it Teresa
named the little girl Claire closing in
on the next house they take a break to
rest but that's when they run into the
man from earlier his cut off hand has
now become infected but he tells her
that she must pay for what she did to
him knowing that she can't touch him
Teresa lets the man do what he wants but
suddenly the man gets knocked over with
a piece of wood pissed off the man
rushes over to beat the out of
Claire at the speed of sound Teresa
rushes to the man putting a knife
directly against his throat telling him
that she will break the rules and
decapitate his head right here if he
touches Claire one more time the man is
horrified and runs away and Teresa goes
to check on Claire and that's when the
girl finally begins to start talking and
asks if Teresa is okay making Teresa
realize that despite their differences
they both share the same suffering and
she drops down to hug her the next day
they finally reach the next town Teresa
quickly kills the one Yoma terrorizing
the villagers and then she asks them if
they can look after Claire the two wave
their goodbyes and Teresa leaves a
little while later while she is walking
in the forest she hears the sounds of
horses passing her nearby sensing
something is wrong she goes to check it
out and sees the same bandits from
earlier headed directly for the village
that she left Claire in she rushes back
to go rescue Claire realizing that the
bandits were waiting this whole time in
the forest waiting for someone to kill
the Young in the village finally getting
there she sees the town Up in Flames men
being slaughtered and the women and
children being taken bodies lying on the
streets and the bandits welcome Teresa
and tell her that she is their hero
right as Claire is heard screaming in
the background helpless against the
bandits okay Teresa was dumb as hell if
I was her I would never have left Claire
alone just like that instead I would
have hid in the woods close to the
village and sat there throughout the
night and paid attention to anybody who
either came or went from the village
that way I would have been able to keep
an eye on Claire and also get ready for
the likely possibility of the bandits
coming by here looking for me for
revenge and if they do show up which
they probably will I'll be able to lead
them away from the village and Claire by
taking them on a wild goose chase
through the woods coincidentally taking
them through my setup which I'll call
the sexy Lumberjack kill zone or
actually I mean accident Zone the town
is surrounded by a dense forest and
knowing this what we could have
essentially done was what Wildlife
biologists do with trees that they want
to cut down in a Safe Way which is a
process known as felling a tree the
chainsaw or ax for example cuts a tree
in the direction that it's leaning in
were superhuman so we could use our
sword instead of a chainsaw to cut and
insert a notch wedge into the front side
of the tree about a quarter distance of
the width of the tree cutting the tree
in this specific way would have allowed
us to essentially weaken the tree in
advance from here in order to make the
tree fall over because of our Notch
wedge all we would have had to do would
have been to cut the tree just a little
bit deeper into the wedge causing our
tree to fall just like taking out that
last piece in a Jenga puzzle it causes
everything to crash and we're basically
doing the same thing and if the bandits
happen to be in the way well accidents
happen all the time as a clamor our
superhuman speed would have allowed us
to pull ahead of the bandits chasing us
and then Circle back to get ready to do
some Lumberjack chopping and the rule
states that Claymores are forbidden from
inflicting physical harm to humans but
that doesn't mean trees falling because
of gravity can't wink wink and it also
doesn't mean that we can't intimidate
them into giving up and running away
terrified because if I'm the bandits and
I just had some of my crew die from
freaking trees falling on them and then
I find a Teresa missing my neck by just
a few inches with a giant sword I would
be more than happy to give up on the
idea of Revenge and then from here we
have the choice to either leave Claire
there or take her with us my vote is
leave her because she is only going to
be a liability and I don't have to save
her every freaking time this Bandit
tells her that he'll watch over Claire
for her and she loses her mind and
quickly kills him in one swift move
everyone here is shocked but the Bandit
later laughs telling her that she knew
she would crack eventually stepping off
his horse he whips out his sword he
calls his Falcon sword and tells Teresa
that no one has ever been able to defeat
him he charges at Teresa but she easily
slices through him like butter eyeing
the rest of the bandits with piercing
cold eyes she Slaughters every last one
of them and Claire then wakes up just as
Teresa's Handler arrives and they both
witness what she's done a few days later
Teresa is called upon to mate with other
claim Wars they declared that since she
broke the rules of their kind and
murdered humans she must now pay the
ultimate price death swords drawn Teresa
prepares to die right here while Claire
cries out to her in horror but Teresa
suddenly acts with speed and disables
all the Claymores around her blood
dripping on her sword shocking everyone
she tells them that she can't afford to
die yet and Claire goes to hug her she
announces to them that she's found a
reason to live the Handler tells her
that she'll regret her decision later he
goes back to talk to the big boss of the
Claymore organization but he tells the
Handler that what Teresa just did is no
big deal he orders the Handler to
organize Claymore numbers two through
four to hunt down Teresa these Warriors
are second ranked only to Teresa and are
now hungry to take her spot as number
one and they begin to initiate the
beginning of the end for Teresa and also
the world later other Claymores are
dispatched to meet up at this human Nest
ranks 3 and 4 link up easily slotting
hordes of Yoma like it's nothing and
they get stopped by their leader the
number two warrior in the world she
reveals to them that that they've been
tasked with a dangerous mission to go
take down the number one warrior in the
world Teresa she also mentions that they
will be waiting on another member to
join them soon the Claymore named Elena
tells her soldiers that this new person
is actually the new number two Warrior
having just completed her training in
two months she's that good Elena tells
these two that her ranking has dropped
to number three while theirs has dropped
to four and five these two get shocked
and pissed off but Elena says that they
can try fighting the new number two for
the title if they want to risk their
lives and that's when they hear the new
number two clumsily running out from
this Alleyway and she collapses on the
floor introducing herself as Priscilla
and she starts crying telling everyone
she's sorry for being late and begs for
their forgiveness oh my gosh number
three and four notice that this is a
little weird not just because she's
weird but because they noticed the trail
of death falling behind her thousands of
Yoma corpses Elena warns them that
Priscilla is the only Claymore who is
powerful enough to kill without using
her Yoma power to help her just like
Teresa and soon she will surpass Teresa
and become the number one hunter in the
world meanwhile Teresa and Claire
continue to go on the Run reaching this
town she runs into a Yoma not wanting to
raise attention to them she considers
letting it roam free but Claire
convinces her to help the people and she
easily Slaughters it this hotel owner
thanks them and offers them to stay in
his hotel for free seeing Claire
exhausted she accepts the man's offer
and they rest up but that's when she
senses three Yoma power sources entering
the town and realizes that she just made
a huge mistake the other Claymores have
found her she quickly suppresses her
Yoma Aura to darn near undetectable
levels so she isn't discovered okay this
makes no sense in how they handled
things which is why I'm going to act
like the German Christmas devil known as
Krampus and use the town's innocent
civilians to help me escape let me
explain at this point Teresa's stupidity
has now shown in the greatest light
possible because how she handled trying
to run away was dumb as hell if I was
her I would not have listened to Claire
at all about saving any
Oma in this Village screw that idea I
would not have taken her feelings into
account and stopping at this hotel was
risky however nice I'm sure the hotel is
because think about it as a claymore we
can go on for days without food and
water and the only reason we would have
had to rest was because of Claire which
is why upon first entering this town I
would have got a hold of a ride don't
you think one horse and carriage combo
one with plenty of cargo room because
we're going to need plenty of space for
the corpses traveling on foot in general
was not really smart because you're on
foot you're not exactly traveling at
light speed to get out of there plus why
waste all of that energy but with a
horse and carriage and plenty of space
for the bodies I mean people I would
have then enacted my Krampus plan
Krampus my good weeps is an old folktale
story about a German devil that snuck
into the houses of all the naughty
children during Christmas and unlike
Santa cramp is lured to little children
with candy and then capture them and
stuff them in his bag and then later
though he ate their flesh which is why
using my horse carriage I would then
begin kidnapping a whole lot of people
women and children and order all of them
met to go fight the Claymores and buy me
some time if they want to have even a
chance of seeing their families again
what I gotta do what I gotta do because
we need to put as much distance between
us and the hunting party that is after
us and the more distance we can put
between us and Them the harder it will
be for them to sense us because
Claymores the closer they get to Yoma
energy the better they can figure out
where exactly it is sounds simple hard I
know but it's our only shot we have to
get out of here quickly Elena quickly
finds Teresa thanks to the public and
declares that she's here to take her
life she takes out her Sword and the two
go at it Claire wakes up in horror just
as another Claymore attacks from the
window quickly evading Teresa escapes
with Claire outside but suddenly notices
another Soldier standing behind her she
realizes that she was unable to detect
her standing there and thinks that this
girl might just be her biggest threat
Priscilla introduces herself and
politely says that they will be taking
her life because of the shame that she
has brought upon their organization she
texts Teresa with a faster speed than
any Claymore before her and the others
watch Elena tells these two that Teresa
is the the best because she can fight
without using her Yoma Powers at all
just like her but then Priscilla
suddenly gets injured and these two get
shocked but Elena smiles and reveals
that it's now their time to strike
everybody is confused Elena tells them
that while Priscilla has the talent to
kill Teresa one day she still needs more
training meanwhile Teresa prepares to
kill Priscilla but notices Claire in the
background seeing her cuteness she
decides like a dum-dum to spare
Priscilla's life and the other clay most
quickly surround her and try to trap her
supercharging with their Yoma Powers but
Teresa easily uses her Yoma detection
skills to see all of their moves and
quickly defeats them not using her
powers at all leader Elena is horrified
that they underestimated her Teresa then
tells them that they can keep on coming
after her and she will keep on beating
their asses and then she and Claire
leave the village Elena quickly goes to
check on her teammates but notices
Priscilla acting weird she begins crying
and starts to show signs that she's
crazy like truly insane and she tells
Elena that what Teresa did to the
organization was unforgivable and she
must be stopped Elena tells her to chill
out a little bit but then suddenly she
releases her Yoma powers and charges off
to stop Teresa and she catches up to
Teresa but now she looks different
unleashing her Yoma powers to its near
Max Teresa tells her that she's not
experienced enough to release this much
power and if she keeps this up soon she
will turn into a full-blown Yoma and
won't be able to turn back catching up
to her she attacks with full-on anger
and no Clarity and she manages to cut
Teresa and this pisses Teresa off and
for the first time he uses 10 of her
Yoma Powers eventually overpowering
Priscilla and she tells the young girl
that she's already using 70 of her
powers and warns her of the horrifying
Stakes that she is about to face if she
uses 80 of her powers she will turn into
the very thing that they were trained to
hunt and she'll lose her Humanity in the
process still angry Priscilla doesn't
listen and goes full-blown Yoma sealing
her face and she becomes a full-on
monster with a little Humanity left she
realizes what she's done and begs
everyone to help but Teresa tells her
it's too late realizing she's done for
Priscilla accepts her fate to die and
she readies her sword but it's too late
the group's stare in confusion Teresa's
hands lay next to Claire and somehow
Priscilla has cut off Teresa's head and
then she unleases her full-on Yoma
powers and turns into something much
worse an awakened being oh I'm so sad
I'm really bummed out like why didn't
Theresa die sooner why is she still
alive let me explain Teresa at this
point is a veteran Claymore the best of
the best apparently and therefore she
knew exactly what all the Claymores went
through including their recruitment
process and training process and this
part is important Claymores are simply
humans made with yomas half monster half
human kind of like blade and unlike how
it was in World War II no one ever signs
up to become a claymore they're forced
into it and this suspicious organization
routinely kidnaps children from families
that were killed by Yoma or ones that
don't have anybody that cares about the
kids and from there they split their
body open and insert yomo flesh into the
human body then they trained the
children to be their foot soldiers from
a young age seeing how devoted Priscilla
was to the organization shows why around
40 percent of the world's armed
organizations have children in their
ranks this is a real thing they force
children into service at a young age why
kids are easier to manipulate
considering the world of Claymore all
these soldiers are walking time bombs
when it comes to their mental health and
Priscilla was no different being young
made her especially more susceptible to
acting out of Blind Faith and devotion
rather than logic compared to the older
women in the group especially Elena this
made her a much more obvious threat to
begin with and even if she was super
powerful it doesn't matter she was
batshit crazy and everybody knew it but
did nothing about it Teresa knew all of
this and yet still chose to spare her
life the first time she went soft on her
all because of one tiny adorable cute
little problem Claire made Teresa soft
weak and distracted and this is what
killed her rising from the
transformation Priscilla likes her new
powers and announces that she is now
craving flesh and wants to bury her head
so she can Chomp their intestines
walking towards the others she swiftly
kills the lame Claymores and slits
Elena's neck and she watches her
greatest failure walk straight towards
Claire Frozen in fear the girl can't
move but Priscilla ends up walking right
past her and flies away going to collect
Teresa's warm decapitated head she runs
back to the town nearby and confronts
Teresa's Handler wanting Vengeance she
begs this man to use Teresa's flesh to
turn her into the one thing that will be
able to stop Priscilla and now her
journey as a claymore begins years later
Claire now a claymore goes through the
ranks training for the day she'll meet
her arch nemesis heading to this Village
for her next assignment she senses
countless Yoma that are hiding within
this town scouting the area she runs
across this kid and he tells her that
the Yoma killed most of his family and
he wants her to stop them but Claire
tells him to pass off later the kid goes
back to his house but discovers his
uncle dead on the floor and then he
spots a Yoma staring at him dead in the
face angry he charges at the beast but
gets caught as about to be devoured when
Claire crashes through the roof smelling
the Yoma scent on the kid's clothing
earlier she takes out her sword and
quickly slices its body parts off one by
one leaving town she realizes that the
kid from earlier has been following her
he tells her that since she saved his
life he must now repay her somehow he
reminds Claire of herself and she
decides to keep him on as her assistant
just like Teresa did with her a few days
later she gets word by her bosses to
meet up with other Claymores in town as
the situation has changed more and more
Yoma a stronger kind have begun to take
over the land they're not like the old
school Yoma these creatures are known as
voracious eaters Claire stops to meet
her Handler first and demands that she
be put on the team to hunt down monsters
like Priscilla because she thinks she's
ready but the Handler shoots down her
request and reveals something even more
terrifying he tells her that awakened
beings and voracious eaters are the same
thing the public thinks voracious either
are Yoma that have gotten too old but
they're actually Claymores just like
Claire but they've lost control of their
powers just like Priscilla has the
public can never know of the
organization's failure to not be able to
control their own soldiers which is why
Claire must take this secret to her
grave Okay so we've just grown up into a
Bodacious Bodacious hottie fantastic
news but in order to deal with Priscilla
we're gonna need more than that I'm
gonna take a page right out of NASA's
handbook in order to defeat her let me
explain Priscilla has just turned into
an awakened being which are Yoma hybrids
that have gone past their Yoma limit of
80 percent they're much more dangerous
they're strong they're bad crazy
and have lost all of their Humanity at
least that's how it is for most of them
and the fact that the organization has
been keeping the origins of these things
a secret from us is that kind of tells
me that we can't trust them and they're
evil anyways we should be more careful
about what questions we ask them from
now on but right now worrying about
Priscilla should be my number one goal
because she took down my adopted muscle
mommy not cool and while Theresa may
have acted did like the most stupid
person in the entire planet for how
gullible she was she was very nice so we
gotta avenge her right now in order to
take on Priscilla I would look into the
relationships between awakened beings in
general while many of these creatures
have lost their Humanity it's clear that
their form and thinking patterns are
based on their personality that they had
when they were human which is something
that we can use I would take a page
right out of a rather controversial
person the dude's name is Verna Von
Braun this dude was the top ballistic
guys for the Nazis during World War II I
know he's really bad he had thousands of
people working for him in horrific
conditions and was a scumbag who
belonged in Hell however though after
the war America recruited his evil
brains and put him to work to combat the
Soviets in the space race and they had
him joined NASA he was the chief
architect of the Saturn V launch the
vehicle that brought the Apollo
spacecraft to the moon the lesson to be
learned from this example is that the
Americans recruited their former enemy
to take down their enemy the Soviets
using that example means that I would
look into different awakened beings to
begin to try to figure out if any of
them have any disagreements between each
other such as territorial disputes find
and awaken being and convince them to
take down Priscilla because it's likely
somebody must have hated her guts at
some point and want to take her place as
one of the strongest awakened beings in
the land in short find an enemy to take
down another enemy the Handler tells her
that unless they get in order to take
out an awakened being they are forbidden
from hunting it themselves Claire begs
him to give it a shot and he agrees to
test her putting her on a special Squad
she gets sent to meet up with her new
team and they prepare to go hunt an
awakened being meeting her teammates
this woman introduces herself miria the
commanding officer of the hunter ranked
sixth seventh time hunting a voracious
eater dinner rank 15 second time hunting
a voracious eater and Helen rank 22 no
experience hunting a voracious eater
they asked Claire her Rank and if she
has experience and that's when she
reveals her pathetic power level rank 47
experience zero everybody begins
laughing just like I would as she he's
weak and she tells the kid that there
are only around 47 districts in this
world meaning Claire is the lowest
ranked hunter in the world Claire leaves
the kid at the village and the Claymore
group goes off to hunt for their
terrifying Target later they set up camp
for the night and later miria tests out
Claire's Powers normally only Warriors
ranked 30 are lower are put on these
types of dangerous missions and she
doesn't believe Claire is as weak as she
looks they quickly fight it out and they
observe her moves and notice something
but queer quickly gets outmatched and
the other two claimers watch and laugh
the next day they head into the
mountains but come across this sweet man
he tells them that he was the one who
called for their help emeria quickly
tries to cut his throat but it's too
late as the other realized that she's
been badly wounded and the man
transforms into their true Target of a
racist eater the group is shocked
realizing that he's the first male
Claymore they've ever seen miria tells
him that there must be some sort of
mistake they were never given any intel
about a male Target okay this is the
first male Claymore that we've ever come
across which means the only way to take
him out will be flirting the out of
him let me explain male Claymores have
crazy strength way stronger than any
female awakens being however when in
their human form for some reason their
Yoma power level is so low that it makes
them undetectable to all Claymores and
that is why Maria couldn't sense that
this guy was an awakened being until it
was too late years ago the organization
used to create male Claymores but
stopped making them eventually as they
all kept turning into awakened beings
unlike the women the reason why many
Claymores used their full powers and
turned into awakened beings is because
the transformation feels sexual yeah it
feels really good because of this it's
hard for many to resist the urge into an
awakened being so in short because a lot
of men are horny a lot of them had a
hard time not getting turned on but
their horniness is something that we
could use look everybody here is a boss
babe which means that we could work hard
but also play hard which means that we
should try to seduce and flirt with the
male awakened being by coming onto him
super hard by using our feminine charms
we could distract him on the other three
playmores pretend to run away in fear
and then went up close we gave him a
little bit of sugar distracting him long
enough for the other Claymores to sneak
in and attack from above and in doing so
we will be able to put a stop to his
horniness once and for all they try to
defend themselves but the metal quickly
kills denave and they see her fall off a
cliff taking her arm it spits it back at
them Helen charges at him but misses and
the male catches her and throws her back
quickly trying to stretch out her arms
and she manages to cut the male's arms
off but they regenerate instantly
they're horrified just as denave Rises
back from the dead with her arm
regenerating faster than they've seen
any Claymore do it before miria thinks
it's impossible that she could
regenerate that quickly and suddenly
notices that these girls are using their
powers more efficiently than any other
Claymore has ever done before and none
of them realize that they're being
watched in the distance the Claymores
quickly tried to come up with another
game plan the male laughs and asks them
why do they think they were sent to take
him down and reveals to them that they
were sent on a suicide mission by their
own kind he instantly kills denevieve
and shoots his hands through Claire and
stabbed Helen while their leader watches
in horror the male tells her that he
will make her feel pain and despair
before he kills her miria quickly tries
to rescue the girl but she sees them
already healing at record speeds the
monster tries to attack her but she uses
her speed to dodge every attack knowing
that eventually she will run out of
speed he waits till she runs low on
energy and he finally manages to catch
her and begins to make her squeal in
pain meanwhile the girls begin to slowly
wake up the male sticks his tongue
inside of her ripped open stomach and
she screams in horror the other girls
try to save her but they're too weak and
all they can do is watch but Claire
somehow manages to get up picking up her
sword and walks towards the monster
shocking everyone the male tries to
strike Claire but keeps missing miria
realizes that Claire has disabled her
Yoma Powers completely and since the
monster is using all of his Yoma Powers
Claire can see all of his moves before
he makes them Claire walks right up to
the monster and quickly cuts off his
body parts one by one almost killing him
but gets knocked back Maria gets back up
and tells Claire that she still needs
training and her and Claire prepare to
take this ugly bastard down killing him
for good now all healed up Maria
suspicially asks her girls if any of
them have been on the verge of Awakening
before and wouldn't you not they reveal
they all have looking serious miria
realizes that everyone here are known
troublemakers to the organization and
since they've already been nearly
awakened this likely explains their
powers and could also mean that the
organization sent him on this mission on
purpose miria also reveals that she
nearly awakened before as well and tells
the girls that she's actually been
investigating the organization that this
whole time since they treat Claymores
like disposables she's been conducting
investigations in secret so that way
they don't find out but she hasn't
learned anything and she thinks that the
organization has decided to get rid of
her and tells the girls that she thinks
everyone here is actually already
awakened they just haven't realized it
yet based on the powers that she saw
them use earlier stretching arms healing
instantly all of those are examples
because for a normal Claymore that's
impossible and just then denove wakes up
emeria tells them that they could awaken
at any time which makes all of them
dangerous then evade decides to test
this Theory out turning on her Yoma
Powers she tries to instantly heal
herself pushing her powers to the
maximum and then she tries to turn back
into a human she tells the other girls
that if she turns into a monsters then
the girls should be ready to kill her
transforming her body starts healing
rapidly and the girls are ready their
swords but she makes it back and keeps
her humanity and this bold really
dangerous move confirms Miriam's Theory
they're all already awakened Claire then
senses that someone is watching them but
Maria tells them that within the
mountain no one will be able to hear
what they're saying and She lays down
the game plan she tells the girls to not
tell the organization what they all now
know and all the while she will continue
to secretly investigate them and also
mentions that because they have now
awakened they are now as powerful as
someone within the single digit ranking
and tells them to watch out for Claymore
levels 5 or below writing down the top 5
Warriors they should look out for
warning them about to number four
especially miria tells them that number
four has no care for clan wars or human
life and is obsessed with hunting
awakened beings they must avoid her at
all costs her name is Ophelia they also
must keep a low profile because if
anyone finds out their secret They're
All Dead miria tells them that anything
she finds out she will report back to
them and tells them to not let their
guard down until they meet again and
everyone agrees to join forces in secret
until they eventually meet again but
what did you think about the video what
would you do different don't forget to
like subscribe and leave a comment down
below and as always check out our how to
be playlist